Ізюм Мабуть це не вища точка Харківщини
і тут я думаю зупинялися на всіх хто з
2014 року їхали на звільнену донеччину в
культовому ресторанчику у вітрів
обов'язково брали каву для того щоб
подивитися на фантастичні краєвиди згори
де річка і ліси абсолютно фантастична
слобожанська природа і вже потім
починається Донбас баби стоять все інше
вщент зруйновано тому що в 2022 році
сюди знову пройшов в русский мир Ну і
від кафе вітрів не залишилося Нічого І
тільки вітер зараз там розносить шмотки
цього приміщення це Краматорськ Сьогодні
ми тут біля офісу європейського
солідарності дуже чумливі відчуття де
більше року не була в Краматорську і
дуже важко спостерігати як сьогодні тут
деградує безпекова ситуація в місті
щоденні обстріли наслідки ос вобождения
рошистов на жаль це трапилося перед
самим першим вересня тільки
відремонтована школа і Такий вигляд
мають всі навчальні заклади не тільки
дружківки а так само Костянтинівка
Слов'янська і Краматорська у восьмій
ранку в цю триповерхівку Краматорська в
центрі міста вчора прилетів російський
снаряд російська ракета і зруйнувала от
просто жили приміщення де в цей час
перебували люди стріляють ракети падають
конечно страшне дело і садики школи і
дома і що это а мешканці збирають те що
залишилося від їх осель одяг якийсь речі
там бібліотеки І це жахливе видовище
коли люди збирають отаку частинку свого
життя вірніше все життя від якого
залишилися тільки частинка які прийшли
на нашу землю вони роблять тільки це так
що нічого хорошого як сказати і
вважається
місцеве населення яке залишається жити в
Краматорську слов'янську потребує
особливої допомоги без роботи он дети
потікали кто куда или без роботи сидять
или когда-то Поехали на заработки перший
місяць Ми залишились тут було дуже
страшно і наші діти боялись дуже літаків
і все готове вирішили поїхати до родичів
на Західну Україну Там перебували
декілька місяців потім зрозуміли що наші
збройні сили мужній вони здатні
втримувати позиції вирішили повернутись
багато вернулися уже назад А там що
гроші позаканчувались і все Денег нет за
квартиру платить їсти надо і їдуть назад
А у кого що вже осталось кауциле в кого
вже як сказати розтрощене чи як там
частічно отаких от будинків Краматорську
сьогодні дуже і дуже багато тому що
безпекова ситуація в місті дійсно
деградує постійно Тут сирени звучать
повітряною тривоги російські ракети сюди
літають безкінечно знищуючи
інфраструктуру знищуючи житлові будинки
школи дитячі садочки
не можна це дивитися на жаль в таких
умовах приходиться жити але Ми віримо в
наші збройні сили люди згадуються в 14
і після звільнення міста а тут відбулися
дуже серйозні ремонтні роботи побудували
нові школи садочки фонтани будівлі і
здавалося що краматорс дуже був
симпатичним місто багато зелені нові
сквери те що зараз відбувається От після
приходу знову-таки російського сюди міра
з його снарядами бомбами просто викликає
великий біль і суд а дні будують а
другий руйнують і очевидно що Наша
задача зробити все для того щоб Росія
відповіла і за Краматорськ теж має бути
створена міжнародною спеціальною
трибунал в якому Росія Путін все
російське керівництво мають відповісти
за злочин агресії за злочини війни за
злочини проти людяності і геноцид пока
вот взрыв би прогріли піде Московську І
вообще летают у самольоти літають то я
не знаю що воно там ви єдиний у нас
священик Української Православної церкви
на Краматорський район
завтра
9:30 ще одного нашого воїна нашого
колеги
на жаль це моє завдання А як от так
пояснити взагалі Хіба це нормально Що
священики
військові церкви да які Ну тут і на
гонщиками працювали і таке інше досі
я їх особисто знаю це ж думають це ж
Дони вони нікуди не ділись вони тут
сидять і діалоги там на першому місці
діалоги іменно Россия виновата
Путіну вообще красавчик Молодец Скоріше
б нас захватили щоб ми тут були рашкою
потрібно якнайшвидше прийняти закон щодо
заборони кремлівської церкви тому що ці
ж донину не мають права просто
вчасно Ми живемо в правовому
господарстві Де Коли я приїжджаю мимо
цієї фсбної контори а їх у нас багато в
Краматорську і там стоїть купа машин
навіть
влаштоморських деякі стоять там Потому
що вони як були московськими Так вони і
є московськими і якими були вишиванки не
ходили але то знаєте скільки людей які
мікрогурують тобто роблять вид що вони
українці але ходять Московську церкву
люблять Московського па-па і якщо трошки
колупнуть вивести на розмову там
українського нема нічого разом з
Володимиром марівим Ми сьогодні додаємо
багатодітним родинам генератори від
наших польських друзів це фонд фонд
серця які передали більше 20 генераторів
сьогодні для жителів Краматорська
Слов'янська дружківки серед нових наших
знайомих є родина в якій 12 дітей і в
ситуації коли немає світла немає
опалення це дуже і дуже важлива дуже
раді що ми вдома скільки тут будемо ми
знаємо але Сподіваємось що вже нікуди
звідти не поїдемо раді бачити що наша
літають що це свої щось відбувається
добре значить